voulez que je vous donne mon avis
comment non mais comment ils ont eu
l'interview euh bah ils ont alors ça ça
fait des truc beaucoup ah oui
oui je dis non moi je la trouve nul
cette interview je vais pas dire que
c'est voilà que je l'aime non mais elle
est elle est
elle bon alors je donne pas mon avis
mais elle a pas je veux dire on lui pose
pas les questions qu'il fe on est comme
question un moment faut vraiment que je
à un moment elle parle des hôpitaux moi
franchement j'aurais pas écrit ce a
écrit ce qui a écrit dans le papier hein
donc voilà ça moi ça bah du qu'elle est
très à l'écoute de des gens dans les
hôpitaux et que pendant le covid elle a
elle a
notamment créé des endroits pour que les
les les les les soignants se reposent
bah moi ça me fait douement rire mais
bon voilà mais c'est mais mais bon c'est
vrai que je suis désolé je suis pas je
suis peut-être pas la meilleure personne
mais moi moi en tant que journaliste en
tant que journaliste je trouve que voilà
il y a des choses qui me dérangent et
pour moi c'est c'est un article de
commun
un moment où il est important de
communiquer
positivement spé
Chun POS parce que c'est toujours bon
pour l'image présidentiel quand même
mais je pense que tu attends trop d'une
première dame elle est pas elle pas
question moi j'aurais posé question sur
les violences conjugales qui ont
augmenté sur la pauvreté qui a
augmenté est par par
avoir
rôle par c'est oui moi j' a plus
interrogé sur sa relation avec Emmanuel
enfin moi de savoir que elle a mangé
qu'elle mange des œufs à la coque
quoiore moi j'adore ça sauf que tu sais
très bien que le protocole de l'éisée va
dire non mais tout ce qui relève de la
politique elle peut pas en parler c'est
impossible très bien qu'Emmanuel que
Brigitte Macron
a PIR énorme à l'Élysée donc même d'as
non regarde blan elle l'adoré il est
parti non mais d'accord mais elle le dit
elle à un moment elle dit elle connaît
mieux le terrain que son mari parce que
elle au moins elle s'est écoutter enfin
c'est dit dans le papier c'est pas mais
ça ça c'est de l'influence ça là-dessus
elle peut pas voilà c'est ces moments au
petit-déjeuner où durant les les dîners
ou les déjeunés qu'elle peut avoir une
certaine influence sur lui mais je pense
qu'il faut pas en attendre plus que ça
je c'est sûr qu' faut pas en attendre
mais c'est vrai que moi j'aurais aimé
qu'on développe davantage sur la
relation quand même c'est un couple
amoureux c'est ça qui est bien elle
explique quand même
oui mais écoutez une seconde elle
explique pourquoi elle est amoureuse moi
ça ça m'a intéressé elle est amoureuse
de son intelligence de cette mémoire
extraordinaire tu vis au pays des
bisounours quoi enfin 39 ans 15 ans moi
je sais pas enfin voilà mais bon bref
mais qu'est-ce qui vous gêne là-dedans
je comprends pas
là elle a droit d'être amoureuse quand
même écoute tu es contre le vaccin tu es
contre la tu es contre tout toi pas
contre l'amour je suis pas cont mais en
fait Catherine ne qui a fait l'interview
l'excellente interview dans Paris mass
explique qu'en fait elle était tellement
passionnée par son métier de de prof d'
que en fait elle aimit elle était
presque amoureuse de tous ses élèves et
elle a été vraiment amoureuse de celui
qui était le plus brillant parce qu'elle
dit qu'elle l'a toujours admiré même d
qu' dit même quand il était son élève
c'était le plus brillant le plus
intelligent elle il a toujours bluffé
donc voilà ça c'est intéressant je suis
désolé qu'est-ce a pensé toi moi je
trouvais c'est une interview sublime
franchement
c'était non non mais
franchement c'est très c'estès c'est
très rare qu'il a une interview aussi
longue aussi prolifique sur les sur des
prières dames comme ça et puis elle se
livre moi j'ai senti la sincérité dans
l'interview j'ai senti qu' voilà masquit
pas les choses elle en parla voilà elle
peut pas non plus rentrer dans dans les
détails sordides relation et
cé Mo
trou non mais intime je dire la question
que pose la question pas sord intime je
voulais dire question que tu poses c'est
la question de la différence d'âge
autant c'est pas une question tabou dire
les choses tell qu'elles sont elle le
dit autrement elle le dit autrement
après moi j'ai une question pour Miriam
si vous aviez pu avoir l'interview vous
l'auriez faite l'interview bah alors
voilà donc c'est un beau cous on peut
saluer le beau coup de la conser
franchement mais on sait très bien
comment ça se passe dans ces
CASL que c'està-dire c'est
quoi des tractations entre entre
l'Élysée le cabinet de de Brigitte et la
rédaction c'est relu c'est et puis
mêmeiam il faut dire il faut dire avant
que il y a des briefs sur sont les
thèmes sur lesquels on
all quand je fais une
interview fais comme ça exactement comm
question après cette interview elle est
faite parce que Brigitte Macron elle
sait très bien que dans ce voilà moi si
elle veut Brigitte Macron je l'intervie
quand elle
veut je pense que voilà ça fait partie
aussi d'une stratégie de communication
et les journalistes le savent très bien
tout le monde a envie de l' voir en
interview malheureusement tu te oui
beaucoups qu'on pas envie d'acheter un
journal pour lire lire une interview for
les gens et les gens adore les petit
POS qu'on aime qu'onime pas c'est quand
même la première dame de France qui est
sur Paris Match donc c'est c'est un
beaucoup moi je l'ai pas lu l'interview
saais pas pour chap par
exemple aelà de ça c'est c'est la
première dame n'a pas le droit d'évoquer
la politique française elle a un devoir
de
réserve mais ou de ça dit des ches dit
entes c'est un vrai papier qui semble
comme ça très anecdotique et en fait
quand on creuse elle dit des choses elle
dit des choses notamment de la politique
crois quoi Glo à la coque tu crois que
c'est
pour non mais dans les relations
internation pour l'élevage voilà et à la
coque c'est
pas et surtout je pense que ça fait ça
intéresse beaucoup plus les Français
comme ça lambda de savoir
bien contraire mais quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse pas plus que ça à la
politique il va plus avoir envie de
savoir ce que fait Emmanuel Macron au
petitdéjeuner que de savoir ce qu'il a
fait en politique P personne n DUP sur
le fait que évidemment toute interview
donn on laisser une minute tu vas
cracher ton vin dis tout
ce
Minuty le truc t'elé parce que parce que
le truc c'est que moi je su je suis assz
voilà je suis assez gênée de de de de de
de de parler de briit Macron comme je
parle d'un people lambda parce que ça a
une influence sur la vie des Français et
la façon dont on les décrit dans la
presse donne forcément une image d'eux
qui n'est pas anodine donc ça ça me
dérange après effectivement Paris Match
a un bon coup moi je suis la première à
vous le dire Brig Macron en couverture
ça vend extrêmement bien on va pas se
mentir après moi les sujets que je fais
sur Brigitte Macron c'est pas cela mais
du coup voilàous tout que tu c'est c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils t'ont pas
choisi oui de
quoi non c'est pas que c'est pas sympa
elle sait très
bien laisse une minute je te laisse non
mais c'est hyper ditér enOn sait que
c'est une super prof elle est géniale
que son mari il est
exceptionnel que que voilà c'est alors
moi ce que j'ai aussi adoré c'est
qu'elle dit qu'elle n'est pas femme
politique mais bon on se rend bien
compte que si c'est est une femme
politique et que son avis compte et que
c'est pour ça qu'elle déjeune d'ailleurs
avec avec les les ministres on on est en
train de nous peindre un tableau
idylique de sa relation avec Emmanuel
Macron mais bon je pense qu'il y a quand
même des choses à dire je vais pas le
faire sur ce plateau-là ce soir et et du
coup c'est vrai que ça manque je trouve
l'interview enfin c'est même pas une
interview parce que c'est mélangé il y a
tellement peu de choses dans l'interview
que c'est mélangé avec de l'écriture et
que du coup voilà on en arrive à des
banalités genre Emmanuel Macron il aime
les à la coque merci
voilà elle a tout dit comme ça elle est
tranquille elle va pouvoir rentrer chez
elle se faire vacciner allez on va se
retrouver dans un instant
tout